[Musique]
salut à toutes et à tous bienvenue sur
rt france pour le débrief du dock un
débrief du dock consacré à john cdu
questionne un documentaire que l'on peut
voir sur notre antenne et arte france et
sur notre site internet en podcast est
en replay arte france points à tv on en
parle de ses documentaires avec lara
thomas enseignante et chercheuse en
mathématiques à l'origine du projet dans
ces matches avec la classe préparatoire
aux grandes écoles au lycée claude
fauriel de saint-etienne un programme
similaire à celui de 5 et persil connu
sous le nom de percy jackson le
principal protagoniste que l'on voit
donc dans le documentaire
bonjour la ratoma merci de répondre à
nos questions avant toute chose qu'avez
vous pensé de ce documentaire dance
éducation havas est un passionné qui a
envie de transmettre beaucoup de choses
à ses élèves à travers différents
supports et notamment la danse
voilà qui qui touche beaucoup à la fois
je pense les familles et des élèves
on voit heureux de venir à l'école c'est
justement là dire quelles sont les
similitudes entre votre projet dans ce
thème at est ce que fait percy jackson
alors il ya des similitudes parce que
tout n'est pas exactement pareil je
dirais que sur les similitudes
c'est à la fois sur le but de redonner
confiance aux élèves confiance en eux
confiance aussi en la matière qui est
enseigné à travers la danse enrichir le
lien entre les enseignants et les élèves
rendre aussi la matière que attractive
je vous propose justement de regarder un
extrait de votre projet vous êtes
dernière la caméra regarder il faut
qu'on arrive à domicile notion du
vecteur on est au départ déjà de tout de
suite il faut qu'on se dise voilà ça
c'est un vecteur hockey
[Musique]
direction comme si on avait exclu six
sept huit et un élu
[Musique]
voilà donc un extrait où lara thomas
vous êtes derrière la caméra où on
comprend un petit peu ce qui se passe
dans ce qu'on met ce que vous pouvez
nous en dire plus et nous dira également
comment l'idée vous est venue de créer
ce projet dans cette émeute alors en
fait là sur l'extrait qu'on voit ce sont
des ateliers de répétition en présence
du chorégraphe stéphanois donc de
saint-etienne toufik mardi d'une jeune
compagnie de danse ballet 21 le but en
fait c'est avec mes élèves de classes
prépas de monter une chorégraphie qu'on
a ensuite filmé pour en faire un support
fixe à ré exploiter sur le thème d
espace vectoriel donc c'est une grosse
partie de ce qu'on appelle les lèvres
linéaire dans l'enseignement
scientifique en classe préparatoire qui
posent de plus en plus obstacle aux
élèves notamment parce que des notions
abstraites
ils sont mises en place et mon idée en
fait elle a été inspirée par ce qu'a
fait une chercheuse américaine même si
chez riche en 2017
elle a participé au concours américain
deng xiaoping ch'tis donc dans sa thèse
qui consiste à au travers d'une
chorégraphie filmée de quelques minutes
essayez d'expliquer au grand public le
sujet d'une thèse ici pour elle c'était
une thèse en mathématiques et j'ai
vraiment eu le déclic en voyant son clip
et je me suis dit je veux faire la même
chose avec mes élèves
donc il faut simplement savoir que d'un
petit chiriches pour son clip a fait
danser de danseurs presque professionnel
et moi mon but c'était de faire danser
mes élèves pour que il donne corps aux
notions mathématiques mais qui les
vivent c'est à dire qu'ils les villes de
l'intérieur pour essayer de donner vie
justement à
à des notions souvent vu trop abstraite
et éloignées en fait voilà donc alors
but je voulais plus à ce qu'il dit lui
la danse pour vivre de l'intérieur les
mathématiques vos élèves ce sont des
jeunes adultes pour les classes
préparatoires dont le documentaire donne
s'est dit questionne avec percy jackson
là ce sont des très jeunes élèves
quelles sont les différences
d'apprentissage entre les jeunes de chez
percy jackson et vos jeunes avouent un
petit peu plus grand alors j'ai envie
dire d'abord sur la pratique de percy
jackson en fait ils utilisent comme je
comprends vraiment à travers le
reportage la danse un peu plus comme une
comptine c'est à dire par exemple à
l'école primaire on peut enseigner des
notions qui doivent être automatique un
typiquement la multiplication des
nombres on peut l'enseigné un peu comme
une comptine et lui il y associe les
gestes donc il me semble qu'au contraire
de mon projet ces gestes ne ne
représente pas forcément un nombre ou la
multiplication mais néanmoins vont
vraiment aidé à la mémorisation et c'est
là dessus ou le projet de persil efforts
et le dit lui même il le dit à plusieurs
reprises dans le documentaire c'est que
il utilise la danse comme moyen de
mémorisation et aujourd'hui d'ailleurs
en france on a plusieurs projets qui ont
déjà été montée des études qui ont été
faites par des psychologues et des
pédopsychiatres qui confirme que le
mouvement aide à la mémorisation
en fait avant c'est un moyen
mnémotechnique exactement passé comme ça
que je le comprends dans la pratique de
persil en plus du fait qu'elles rendent
le court vivant attractif on voit
vraiment les élèves heureux notamment
dans cette scène où ils dansent tous
pour répéter les dizaines et les unités
on les sent vraiment aussi concentré et
c'est aussi voilà quelque chose sur
lequel sur laquelle insiste beaucoup
persie c'est que il utilise la danse
c'est pas simplement l'idée qu'il faut
que les enfants soient un mouvement dans
tous les sens mais au contraire à
travers le mouvement essayer de capter à
la fois leur attention et leur énergie
pour en faire quelque chose de créatif à
la cei le il explique très bien aussi
non dans ce documentaire on va justement
il explique très bien je vous propose
d'écouter
percy jackson qui parle d'eux
de son projet extraits l'école classique
c'est comme une école militaire à ce qu
elle a de mon point de vue la danse
fonctionne mieux que les règles
classiques de l'école
[Musique]
merci ne pense pas que les enseignants
devraient toujours exigé la discipline
de la part de leurs élèves
pourquoi alors interdire de faire du
bruit de s'agiter un bon enseignant doit
organiser la foule devenir son leader et
permettre aux élèves de canaliser leur
énergie de manière créative
extrait de dance éducation documentaire
à voir sur arte france et sur rt france
pointe tv en bottes en podcast est en
replay lara thomas ont bien d'entendre
percy jackson 1 qui s'appelle réellement
sac et perd 6 e son surnom sur les
réseaux sociaux
percy jackson on vient de m'entendre
dire je cite la danse fonctionne mieux
que les règles classiques de l'école
pourquoi c'est quoi c'est allier l'utile
à l'agréable
est-ce que l'école est trop poster est
ce que l'art entre est ce que la danse
rend les maths plus accessible je pense
que c'est vraiment l'idée qu'il n'ya pas
un seul support une seule approche pour
enseigner à tous les élèves et
d'ailleurs dans un autre moment
documentaire on voit merci très
impliquée pour peindre par exemple des
coups de crayon avec des couleurs qu'il
a bien choisi et il explique qu'il a
envie de s'impliquer dans de mettre en
place différents supports et ça c'est
très important le rôle de l'enseignant
ces deux sans cesse trouver des
nouvelles approches des nouvelles
pratiques pédagogiques qui vont
s'adapter à la plus la plus la pluralité
excusez-moi des élèves et de leur
situation pour transmettre sans cesse de
nouvelles choses et la danse en fait
partie et je pense que c'est un support
cas pas encore été beaucoup exploité et
pourtant comme le dit persie comme on le
voit tout au long du documentaire alors
au ghana particulièrement la danse est
partout dans la vie de la naissance à la
mort pour célébrer les mariages les
décès il en fait même un parallèle très
intéressant avec la pratique du football
et il pose la question pourquoi ne pas
l'utiliser en cours et je trouve que sa
question est très intéressante pourquoi
la classe doit rester un temps séparés
du monde réel et je pense que c'est
aussi ce qui l'a motivé à dire si mes
élèves ont du mal à apprendre peut-être
que la classe est justement trop poster
dans le sens où elle serait peut-être
trop coupé du monde réel et il a essayé
différents traits la danse qu'il
pratique lui par ailleurs de façon très
poussée comme une façon je pense à la
base d'attirer ses élèves
donc je pense c'est vraiment le côté
attractif vivant qui a motivé son
initiative et ensuite il a observé
que bah ça va être beaucoup les élèves à
mémoriser à se sentir bien au cigare il
ya le bien-être qui est important se
sentir bien en classe
je pense que c'est que c'est utile et je
pense qu usées moi je pense que il
exprime un petit peu sur la fin quand il
parle des danses folkloriques et puis
symbole qui est apportée à tous c'est à
dire aux moindres gestes ou choix des
costumes mon choix des décors etc
les matic les mathématiques pardon sont
appuyés sur un langage symbolique et je
pense aussi que c'est peut-être là où la
danse intervient la notion de symboles
je trouve elle est très très bien et
représente et est exploité en danse vous
dites et percy jackson le dit également
que danser ça aide à mémoriser il dit
d'ailleurs je suis dedans c'est plutôt
qu expliqué mais en quoi la danse peut
aider à retenir le théorème de pythagore
ou à retenir des identités remarquables
comment est ce que vous le faites
gestuellement pour pouvoir retenir tout
ça oui j'ai beaucoup réfléchi à sa
phrase quand il a dit que si on peut
utiliser la danse plutôt que expliquer
ou aux tendances et j'ai encore réussi
aussi à donner à cette phrase moi
j'utilise la danse pour expliquer et non
pas à la place d'expliquer mais
peut-être que justement ce qu'il voulait
dire c'était de ne pas expliquer avec
nos mots nos maux traditionnels et c'est
vrai que souvent on est face à cette
difficulté où on a beau en tant
qu'enseignant être au tableau explique
et répondre aux questions
on voit que ça passe pas peut-être
justement parce que l'eau mots ne
suffisent pas pour expliquer je pense
que c'est ça en fait le sens de sa
phrase à percy jackson
c'est encore une fois utilisé le corps
et tout le langage du corps pour voilà
en fait utilisé un autre langage que
celui qu'on utilise habituellement pour
expliquer un sujet difficile sans quand
vous parlez vous êtes vous êtes
passionné 1 par le projet passionnée par
la danse également par les mathématiques
mais on sait que le niveau des
mathématiques baisse régulièrement en
france comment est-ce que vous
l'expliquez comment y remédier ce que
votre projet peut se démocratiser pour
faire remonter les neutres
comment je l'expliqué bon il ya plein
d'explications mais bon je pense que pas
non plus être fataliste un bon je sais
pas tout précisément notamment sur les
évaluations qui sont en fait et c'est
bon moi mon premier mon premier avis
c'est que on manque de temps de temps et
de moyens et ça c'est pas c'est pas rien
de le dire
c'est à dire que bon notamment en france
par exemple on a réduit le nombre
d'heures d'apprentissage des
mathématiques en collège et il nous faut
du temps pour monter un projet comme les
miens un des plus gros obstacles a été
de trouver du temps pour mes élèves mes
élèves ont un emploi du temps bon ce
sont des annonces dans une filière
sélective
il prépare des concours pour être
vétérinaire et une des difficultés a été
de trouver du temps pour pouvoir caler
mais atelier le temps de tournage donc
on l'a fait en parallèle d'un cd qui
pouvait être supprimés à ce moment là et
surtout les samedis après midi et je
crois que c'est vraiment ça s'est
accordé du temps de la confiance et du
moyen aux enseignants pour qu'ils
puissent mettre en place de tels projets
et ça veut dire quoi du temps pour
qu'ils puissent se mettre davantage en
accord et à l'écouté de tous ces jeunes
qui évoluent beaucoup parce qu'on dit
que la société évolue mais parce que nos
jeunes avant toi parce que ou bien en
conséquence je sais pas mais en tout cas
nos jeunes et rouler aussi beaucoup et
et nous il faut suivre on doit s'adapter
faire évoluer nos pratiques et c est ce
qu on peut généraliser votre méthode
celle de percy jackson dans le
documentaire ou est ce qu'il ya des
limites à ce qu'on peut
transvasez cette technique que sur sur
d'autres matières sur toutes les
matières par exemple oui alors plein de
choses d'abord l'interdisciplinarité et
encourager un aujourd'hui notamment en
collèges et lycées on encourager
consignant a travaillé sur
l'interdisciplinarité et le langage du
corps si je me trompe pas fait partie
des quatre points sur lesquelles
s'appuient ces projets est justement la
danse ont fait partie les mathématiques
à travers la danse aussi
vous me posez la question d'autres
disciplines bien entendu le concours
denso qui étudie par exemple auquel je
faisais référence tout à leur propose de
très chouettes clip sur la biologie par
exemple on voit des
six danseurs qui ai mis des molécules
qui s'accouplent ou pas etc
et je trouve que c'est un ex un
excellent moyen de à nouveau de
transmission à la fois pour l'élève et
pour le grand public et je serai pas
n'est que l'histoire géographie etc
s'applique aussi à ce projet merci
beaucoup à ratoma d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
enseignante et chercheuse en
mathématiques à l'origine donc du projet
d'entité mat avec la classe préparatoire
aux grandes écoles lycée claude fauriel
de saint-etienne un programme donc
similaire à celui que l'on peut voir
dans le documentaire d'anne d'éducation
sur rt france c'est la fin de ce débrief
du dock merci beaucoup la ratoma d'avoir
répondu à nos questions
on se retrouve plus tard sur rt france
by
[Musique]
e